part of this video was sponsored by
Squarespace this is the bmer it's a
neighborhood in Amsterdam compared to
the city's canals briak architecture and
six-story tall buildings the belmer
looks
different its concrete buildings are
arranged like Honeycombs there's lots of
green space and even a raised Metro it
looks strange but a few decades ago it
looked even stranger this is not just
any ordinary City neighborhood Once Upon
a Time the belmer was the city of the
future a City built in a park a Utopia
in
Amsterdam one day it was the country's
largest housing project in history
another day it became its largest
demolished one in a time where the
netherland's urban planning is
borderline fetishized the belmer is
considered by some its biggest urban
planning
failure what is the Balmer
the Netherlands is not known for
high-rise buildings its people are tall
enough so there's not much need for
compensation in the' 60s though there
was an exception y high-rise Estates
dominated the building in this era these
years proed to be the time of peak
housing production in the Netherlands
and many other European countries after
the second world war there weren't many
homes but there were lots of people who
needed them all across Europe new
high-rise neighborhoods developed these
neighborhoods became experiments in new
types of living Architects and planners
believe the time of organic bottomup
cities was over it was now the time to
build them top down artificially c.i.
a.m is a group of the world's most
leading urban planners and Architects we
have designed the cities of the future
the population is too dense within the
historic nuclei of cities structures
built along Transportation routes and
around their intersections are
detrimental to habitation the ratio
between the size of a population and the
land area that it occupies can be
entirely changed by the height of
buildings high buildings set apart from
one another must free the ground members
of CM believe that the design of cities
should divide living working Recreation
and transportation this is the model we
have created for a perfect City
high-rise buildings give room for Green
Space among large populations zoning
separates housing work Recreation and
travel efficient but separated
Transportation connects the different
zones of the city
uniform and standardized buildings give
equal access to sunlight large green
spaces give equal access to clean air CM
was influential but there were few
places in the world that applied their
principles precisely one of the few
places that did was
[Music]
Amsterdam SP for
amsterd for
for and for
[Music]
amstd in the 60s Amsterdam had just
finished the construction of four new
neighborhoods slir star held and oorp
these neighborhoods were supposed to
increase the housing Supply
but they weren't enough Amsterdam wanted
more so the city picked a fight with the
national government and a different
municipality Amsterdam wanted the belir
in its East but the municipality it
belonged to
disagreed the other municipality wanted
to merge with two others to make an
entirely new on-edge government that
could hold the red Amsterdam at Bay the
fear was that if Amsterdam grew too
large the distance between the
representatives and the represented
would be too far
this conflict led to the belmer question
a multi- hour long debate at the
national level on whether the belmer
should go to
Amsterdam in one reality Amsterdam lost
the belmer remained in the hands of the
original municipality and the city today
would have looked quite different but in
this reality Amsterdam won the bmer is
the city of the future as opposed to
those cramped polluting streets in the
center we've built a city in a park
residential homes are separated from
industry but you can easily get to your
work by using raised roads separated
from pedestrian walkways all a working
man needs to do is leave his apartment
walk to the parking garage connected to
his high-rise and get into his car he
can do all of this without getting hit
by a single drop of rain our traditional
European cities are cramped messy and
polluting we've designed a place that
gives you all the benefits of density
without the penalties all the positives
of Rural Life without the negatives
after that long fight with the national
government the mayor of Amsterdam and
the rest of the city council were almost
in complete agreement the belmer was not
just some buildings that would change
Amsterdam it would change cities
forever
the's buildings Road networks bike paths
bus lines and parking garages were all
strictly set from above the goal was
space green and light a key difference
between bmer apartments and your
traditional Amsterdam one is the amount
of room our Apartments can have three
bedrooms a living room storage and a
kitchen Old City Center Apartments
sometimes don't even have their own
bathroom our apartments are an upgrade
by using using concrete and steel we've
been able to stack up large apartments
for middle class families we have all
the benefits of a dense wealthy
neighborhood but with the empty space of
a rural one from the start the belmer
was meant to attract middleclass Dutch
families it was supposed to unlock a new
system of living spacious rooms with
semi-public spaces and recreational
facilities all without sacrificing
nature
on the grounds you could find running
tracks many parks to run and play around
in ideal for a
[Music]
family attention if you or a loved one
was diagnosed with not having a personal
website you may be entitled to the best
website builder on the planet
Squarespace
hug in the 21st century everyone should
have a personal website it's the best
hub for presenting your skills literally
the best place to show your work in
public I now receive a decent amount of
CVS from people looking to help with my
videos they can be impressive but in all
honesty they never leave as much of an
impression as a personal website that
directly shows what that person has
worked on with squarespace's blogging
tools flexible website templates and
email campaigns it's never been easier
to make your own personal website that
stands out in the sea of boring CVS and
check out squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch go
to squarespace.com hog to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain the buildings were 11 stories the
ground floor was used as storage space
this was supposed to give each resident
in the belmer an equal amount of privacy
different housing corporations were
responsible for different groups of
buildings leading to to slight
variations in the monotonous uniform
design the hexagonal arrangement of the
buildings was meant to give each
building an equal amount of sunlight
inside were communal areas and interior
streets that could be used by the
building's residents discover our
Innovative three- tiered transportation
system dedicated roads for cyclists and
pedestrians separate roads for personal
cars buses and trucks an elevated metro
line between the apartments connects you
to the Heart of the City to further
streamline movement in the neighborhood
we've constructed alleys under the
building so that you can bike and walk
beneath them there you can find a stray
junkie who is illegally occupying one of
the apartments a lot of middle class
people do do do not want to live in the
B bmer our apartments are empty our
construction has been delayed our Metro
isn't finished yet so the bmer is
separated and alone the planners planned
incorrectly the bmer did not attract the
amount of people that were expected many
households were turned off by the large
alienating
high-rises so they left for recognizable
suburbs instead the beur flats had to
compete with semidetached houses in
several rapidly developing small towns
surrounding Amsterdam like fand and
almir why the [__] would anyone go to
[Music]
per
if you get an apartment now that the
housing corporations are desperate to
rent it will definitely be worth it in
the future just make sure you don't
spend too much time in the parking
garages under the trees and in the
Alleyways beneath the buildings the
prices in the belmer were too high to
justify moving to such a radically new
place people were less enthusiastic than
the planners had
thought
vacancies led to delayed rents and high
turnover rates the neighborhood
spiraled the public amenities that were
promised became too expensive without
money flowing in from paying
residents
the parking garages which were supposed
to be such an Innovative addition became
instead areas of
[Music]
concern the alleys beneath the buildings
and the interior streets became
increasingly difficult to
maintain
a place that was intended to attract
middle class families just didn't it
attracted poverty
instead the bellmer's design and
negative stigma created a
self-fulfilling cycle the nature alleys
and parking garages helped criminals get
away with crime and made people feel
unsafe poverty reduced its
attractiveness separating the
neighborhood even more in 1975 Serama a
former Dutch Colony became independent
people fled to the Netherlands to escape
the power vacuum that was developing in
their country but when they came to the
Netherlands they were welcomed with a
cold
hand could
in
in in and in
ut no better place to put this new group
of people than where the existing
residents didn't want to go anyway the
belmer became known for its poor and
stigmatized migrant population
[Music]
inip Hoover one of the buildings about
90% of its tenants had a ceremon
background migrant families tended to be
larger which led to overcrowding and
also increased pressure on the public
facilities that were already
weakened the bmer ghettoized it turned
into to an isolated stigmatized
underprivileged urban area in the' 70s
the city pursued distribution policies
spreading out new incoming ceremony
migrants to other parts of the city what
a pretentious video essay way of saying
that entire groups of people were banned
you're not seeing the bigger picture
it's not our fault that other
competitive housing developed or even
that multiple housing corporations
fragmented and delayed Construction in
Amsterdam Center there's always eyes on
the street in the beur we just didn't
have enough eyes when there's lots of
people there's social control it becomes
harder to litter when you feel like
there's other people holding you
accountable however the bellmer's
advertised spaciousness and privacy
became its biggest
[Music]
enemy not enough people meant not enough
eyes on the street not enough eyes on
the street me that the bmer had more
crime hyper Focus Fus on the crime and
then people don't want to go outside not
enough people go outside and then
suddenly you have more crime then we
[Music]
could turn over rates showed that the
bmer wasn't working it was not a place
to live in but a place to work your way
out of
[Music]
the Amsterdam City government have been
slow and waffled around ways to tackle
the negative stigma for years in the 9s
they were forced to in 1992 a 747 L all
cargo plane crashed into the belmer to
this day it is the largest flight
disaster on Dutch soil for the residents
the crash left more questions than
answers and left them feeling more
neglected than accepted
it fueled motivation to demolish some of
the high-rises almost 2/3 of the
original buildings were destroyed in
their place the neighborhood was
densified with low
[Music]
Rises
is
it fa what it
is the original plan that made the
belmer special was modified hallways
underneath the buildings were removed or
made larger the ground floors which were
meant to be storage spaces were
converted into workspaces and new
dwellings the front of the ground floors
were converted into private Gardens
turning public Collective responsibility
into isolated plots of private ownership
today the belmer is still used as a
poster child for the dangers of utopian
Master
planning thank you glow for the intro
and outro song for Vis with help with
the research lar for the footage as well
as the B Museum Andreas and S for help
with the
modeling